berti ringraziamente questo nuovo video
io sono fa vj e oggi siamo tornati sul
l'htc flyer vai bestini giampiero no non
però di nuovo però di rivestirmi farai
dentro quella 2000 e quarta volta è
fatto la stessa cosa non ho ora se ti
dico qui quo qua
ok in post produzione così metto qualche
effetto tipo robotico sei sicuro di
voler stare bene tanti ragazzi e
benvenuti che sono video sono file già
registrati sulla htc fai perché questo
buhari incredibile che ti immerge nel
mondo del matrix e delle tecnologie e
oggi faremo saljic simulator che
conoscete molto bene i guai prima di
cominciare sigla a chi interessa ma con
noa no
anan subuh
anne knight superman allora ragazzi il
problema è che ha il pollice lo chiudo
con questo e poi per il resto come solo
questi due questo posso fare solo così o
avete visto tutti importante quello
quindi ogni tasto a una sua ma va a
cagare
il problema ragazzi che sono un dottore
sono un pò nano perché sono bassissimo
arrivo si pronto tra parlate
sono veramente nano se non fosse per
questo sarei un mondo torre io purtroppo
arrivò soltanto ai testicoli del
paziente però non fa niente ora partiamo
allora giampiero preparati perché questo
sarà una cosa da ricordare per tutte le
sono un nano braille e non arriva
neanche alla faccia del paziente del
giorno e sono veramente basso va bene un
dottore nano all'opera facciamo quello
che riesco la prima cosa è che dobbiamo
triturare la gabbia toracica del
paziente questa è una cosa che ho sempre
desiderato fare in prima persona perché
in questo maledettissimo gioco è sempre
un casino muovere le cose e invece oggi
riusciremo a farlo ma però sembra
veramente di operare una persona è
bruttissimo terribile ok allora questa è
la prima cosa dovevo fare la seconda era
apprezzare questo bell'uomo perché io lo
so campo mi ami non so tesoro vieni qua
questo togliere tra questa cosa ci
separa tra il nostro limonare purtroppo
avete lima nero così addio che schifo
vabbè ci sono dei problemi però è
fighissimo poter fare delle robe in
prima persona ragazzi lo vedi questo
ecco se fai il bravo ok solo scherzando
qua dovrebbe esserci in teoria il cuore
nuovo
mandai a l'altra [ __ ] è ok
fortunatamente uno dei vantaggi di
essere nani è che puoi raccogliere le
cose che ti cadono come se niente fosse
allora questo lo mettiamo in un posto
dove rimane pulito perché un cuore sport
onore nel suono
no no a let's go cuore se l'abbiamo qua
ricordiamocelo signore cosa facciamo
oggi ne paghiamo un polmone che serve
questo è un pokémon glielo regalo per te
provo a fare la schiacciata media come
si fa a fare la schiacciata che ci provo
ce l'ho fatta mi sono fatto male però
che allora mio capo un rene o questo qua
mi se
avevo promesso che non avrei usato per
mi serve perché devo decidere quindi
decido e non ti lamentare grazie madonna
sta morendo
la siringa si ricarica non c'e la
siringa la siringa per fermare
l'emorragia dove eccola
no è morto li mortacci mi è pure pensavo
di fare le cose fatte bene
rifacciamo è stato divertentissimo e
preme che è molto felice di quanto
pensassi
ripartiamo restare ora vi spiego oggi vi
spiega il dottor parigi come funzionano
le cose prima prendere martello togliere
ossa inutili del corpo non servono a
niente se non solo ha difficoltà re
l'operazione quindi via via ossa inutili
prendere polmone buttare polmone prende
l'altro polmone vendere su subito.it che
non serve a niente anzi visto fare un
canestro fatto bene ma attenzione non
per juan che cestista è let's go hard
che verde veramente sangue sto tizio e
la siringa dovrebbe servire proprio a
questo non vedo o si è fermata nel mondo
molto bene l'operazione ancora aperte
sempre molto delicata ragazzi quindi
bisogna trattare le cose con la massima
delicatezza
perché se no il nostro paziente potrebbe
morire allora questo via questo guardi
ho ricavato una collana bellissima
montelago di tura vita non lo so vi sta
schiattando veloce veloce veloce veloce
siringhe da nell'uovo nell'orecchio
perfetto come mai prima non sono
riuscito a salvarlo così che è
miracolosa sta cosa allora lo vedi
questo non funziona va via è la prossima
volta
spegne un po di più ma compri le cose
che funzionano questo qui è l'ultimo
modello di cuore che ho trovato su
amazon fighissimo se riuscissi
all'aperto
ecco questo è un unboxing fatto come si
deve se riuscissi ora incastrare per
bene il cuore non so come si fa però ci
proviamo ha abbassato fuori così niente
colla per attaccarle bene perfetto look
fa into mia inshore gaylib sono sicuro
che lui sopravviverà secondo me no
bisogna mettere anche questo che l'ho
tolto prima adesso al rene rena scusami
per fini la prima operazione nel gioco
era normale che ho messo una vita
ragazzi adesso è molto più easy allora
la seconda operazione è l'operazione di
reni il trapianto di reni quindi te che
possiamo cominciare è fighissimo non sta
roba
sei sempre tu però è fare una vita
normale per cortesia devi capire che non
devi bere che ti riduci così è capito si
ma i regni sono due giustamente da
rappresentare uno sono micro più sono
due duri non lasciarli cade perché ok a
posto a poco non posso il pil arte di
così no per questo troppo bello posso
firmarti rehn è fighissimo fa così ti
ricorderai sempre di mezzi non ricordi
uncino videocamera a cosa perché perché
dovrebbe servirmi una videocamera
faccio il blog guarda qua è perfetto
così almeno ci abbiamo la pesca mi
servirebbe una roba per tagliare quindi
questo perfetto
non so bene dove sono i punti per
tagliare perché come potete vedere
essendo diversamente alto ho dei
problemi è morto da non c'è avvocato
simulator invece
medico è un casino allora via via via
via via saranno cosa devo tagliare qua
cosa devo datevi un bisturi cosa devo
tagliare cosa vuoi cosa dovuta agli arti
zio pena o si è staccato sto parte
inutile le il corpo cosa te ne fa è
caduta da qualche parte non so dopo
allora ma vabbè vabbè sta roba come la
stacco qualcuno audit c'è un google
chiamo dove google quando serve come
staccare lo stomaco una persona come si
stacca lo stomaco staccati togliti non
potevi fare l'operazione dalla schiena
che non cv tutti sti organi da toglie no
facciamo là davanti che dobbiamo
togliergli tutto demonio o mannaia ladra
che non perde sangue non ti serve a
niente butta là per cortesia con il
favore a the next finalmente siamo
arrivati ai due maledetti allora 1 e 2
ok posso svuotarti reni direttamente
dentro molto bene molto bene
via la scatola via tutto perfetto look
sfantu mi farà anche per mezzo a una
prima schiacciata decente che fa direi
provare l'ultima ragazzi facciamo una
cosa fatta bene perché l'ultima è quella
più importante ed è quella del cervello
che servirebbe a pietro cominciamo
allora lazio primo tentativo il cervello
e molto
allora io non ho però giganti per
cortesia mettetevi li più bassi successo
perché buio no allora accende l'ospedale
pagate le bollette per cortesia anche al
buio
devo farla ma siete scemi ma non potrei
non posso mai quando al buio re grande
come con una mano devo tener la torcia e
con l'altro devo operare siete pazzi non
arriva neanche al cervello del paziente
è troppo alto come ti apro la testa come
faccio ragazzi art for man da spese che
mi ammazzo cosa già allora adesso ti
vedo cose non so già che muoio
ricordati che se cade sbatto la testa io
giampiero devi farmi quella cosa che sto
facendo io adesso è ok ci penso io
piano piano piano tipo nuovo tipo luogo
chiarissimo
perché tanta kata il kata kkkk che
lavoro ma che bravo ora commento los
collego il cervello a me basta familiare
una verifica di matematica a eccola
quindi che come parli di matematica si
scollega schiavi sta succedendo una roba
para normalissima non hai idea di cosa
stava accadendo e morendo questo
funziona da dio questo era il mio colori
miniera di pietro o che ho preso una più
più c'è ciampi la sedia o persona più
più sono stato bravissimo
vabbè raga direi che per oggi direi che
per oggi va tutto benissimo è stato
bellissima soprattutto l'ultima
operazione da fare e spero che il video
vi sia piaciuto io dovrò scendere
un giorno ti aiuto io vabbè ma gambe da
milano con la mano e una matita nel
gioco ero ok allora mia madre
ecco come si sentono mette bisogni volta
dai ragazzi io spero che vi sia piaciuto
cose che ci sono pronto mi piace anche
ai soci ha condotto la descrizione
ricordatevi che l'eroe che di cui avete
bisogno non è iron man ma è dottor house
da ragazzino
[Musica]